this is the account of hano king of
Carthage about his voyage to the Libyan
lands beyond the pillars of Herakles
which he also set up in the shrine of
Chronos the Carthaginians all did hano
to sail out of the pillars of Herakles
and found a number of Liberty nishi's
cities he set sail with 65 old ships
about thirty thousand men and women food
and other equipment after sailing beyond
the pillars for two days we found it our
first city called thin iya tirion below
it was a large plain sailing westward
from there we arrived at so various a
Libyan promontory covered with trees
here we dedicated a temple to Poseidon
sailing to the east for half a day we
reached a lake it was not far from the
sea and was covered with many long reads
from which elephants and other wild
animals were eating after our visit to
the lake we sailed on for one day by the
sea we found its cities called Carrick
on teachers get a Accra Malita and a
Rambis
continuing our voyage from there we
reached the Aleks sauce a large river
flowing from Libya the lick sights a
nomadic tribe were pasturing their
cattle beside it we remained with them
for some time and became friends beyond
them hostile Ethiopians occupied a land
full of wild animals it was surrounded
by the Great mountains from which the
lick sauce flows down according to the
lick sites strange people dwell among
these mountains cavemen who run faster
than horses when we had got interpreters
from the lick sites we sailed along the
desert shore for two days to the south
after sailing eastward for one day we
found in the recess of a bay a small
island which had a circumference of five
States we left settlers there and corded
Kurn we calculated from this journey
that this island lay opposite Carthage
for the time sailing from Carthage to
the pillars and from there to kern was
the same sailing from there we crossed a
river called true ettus and reached a
bay which contained three islands bigger
than kern after a day's sail from here
we arrived at the end of the bay which
was overhung by some very great
mountains crowded with savages clad in
animal skin by throwing stones they
prevented us from disembarking and drove
us away leave him from there we arrived
in another large Broad River teeming
with crocodiles and hippopotamuses
returning from there we went back to
Kern
[Music]
from there we sailed to the south for 12
days we remained close to the coast
which was entirely inhabited by
Ethiopians who fled from us when we
approached even to our league sites
their language was unintelligible on the
last day we anchored by some big
mountains they were covered with trees
whose wood was aromatic and colorful
sailing around the mountains for two
days we came to an immense expanse of
sea beyond which on the landward side
was a plain during the night we observed
big and small fires everywhere flaming
up at intervals taking on water there we
continued to five days along the coast
until we reached a great bay which
according to our translators was the
Horn of the West there was a large
island in it and in it a lagoon which
was soaked like the sea and on it
another Island here we disembarked in
daytime we could see nothing but the
forest but during the night we noticed
many fires alight and heard the sounds
of flutes the beatings of symbols and
tom-toms and the shouts of a multitude
we grew afraid and our diviners advised
us to leave this island
[Music]
quickly and in fear we sailed away from
that place sailing on for four days we
saw the coast by night full of flames in
the middle was a big flame taller than
the others and apparently rising to the
Stars by day this turned out to be a
very high mountain which was called
chariot of the gods
sailing vents along the torrents of fire
we arrived after three days at a bay
called Horn of the south in this gulf
was an island resembling the first with
a lagoon within which was another island
full of savages most of them were women
with hairy bodies from our interpreters
called and gorillas although we chased
them we couldn't catch any males they
will escaped being good climbers who
defended themselves with stones
however we caught three women who
refused to follow those who carried them
off biting him coring them so we killed
and flayed them and brought their skins
back to Carthage for he did not sail any
further because our provisions were
running short
[Music]
you